all right guys
just like we rehearsed ready all right
all right all right just like we
rehearsed gentlemen
ready take it away clint you lead us in
all right three
two and here we go
[Music]
[Music]
oh okay okay the middle part the middle
part oh my god i'm putting this
down guys uh we just tried to do an
intro
i'm getting three audio sources into my
one um
this may not go as planned but we're
going for it anyways
we're doing the music cast the first
ever now the plan was to talk about
music but as soon as we started everyone
started playing music
and once everyone started playing music
things kind of just went
went awry from there i'd say the only
person that's qualified to talk about
music
would be sam as well
here's the thing about music it's all
about the notes
and the beat all right if you don't have
meets and music
and or notes you don't have music so you
know you're just going to want to start
there
so go to your piano teacher ask them
what it's all about they'll tell you
more
okay so wait help me understand i'm
going to take notes you need
notes and a beat wait you're going to
take notes
they're different see i can play no
watch i can anyone can do notes
no no same thing can you give me an s
can you give me an s one two three four
five six seven eight
s there it is oh yeah dude actually yeah
i can play an s hold on hold on
a b c d e f g h
i j k l m n o p q r s okay
wait so we're just a bunch of bubs
talking about music why are we qualified
to talk about because music matter you
have personal experiences with it dude
there's no rules in music
yeah everything all your music teachers
lied to you
you know there's no such thing as chords
and scales it's all just a construct
designed to get you to pay
for music lessons that's so deep sam
big music no for real so one one thing
most people
of of today's audience don't know is
that uh
back in what was this guys 2011
yeah we've we were in a band me
sam nico we were in a band with jimmy
wong
yeah and jimmy was was the singer
sam was the lead guitar i was base nico
was drums
and uh we got to play a show at vidcon
2012. i'll never forget this we played
in front of 5 000 people
um yeah it was our first and only show
i don't know how it happened we opened
with an instrumental
we opened with the game of thrones theme
song
that's the oblivion theme song it was an
oblivion elder scrolls game of thrones
mashup which is [ __ ] awesome
yeah then he played and then
yeah and then we actually played some
songs and people were actually singing
along with some of the songs
it was amazing yeah yeah they said they
they knew
the that one i think i think that
they got the game of thrones hype going
we had to challenge saying along with
the instrumental
yeah they're like they're follow lying
so hard
so i know that i i played vidcon with
jimmy years later that was like 2014 i
think
did we ever play together no oh
gotcha officially no i mean we've jammed
out together no i remember jamming out
with you guys in the warehouse across
the street and i remember coming in
and like uh sergio sexy sax man
i remember he came over for a jam
session one time and he brought his
flute
and that was like one of the best jam
sessions i still remember that jam yeah
i remember that too i was like wow
everyone
is like groovin it's so intense uh
yeah i don't know it was super cohesive
yeah i was just feeling the vibe i'm
getting chills just thinking about it
it was amazing so the reason we're doing
this episode
uh the podcast is because music's
actually been a pretty big thing in all
of our lives but it's not like it's not
like a thing that we perform
on like the youtube channel like it's
it's been a personal thing like
maybe it's be i mean maybe because none
of us are like really professionals at
it except for like
samsung i mean
it's relatively professional but like
you're a near professional i mean i've
made money off of selling music in the
sense
so i guess that makes me professional
you have an album and you have a second
one coming out yeah
but but but yeah so yeah i mean i've
gone through the the process but
yeah yeah so you know we've all had
different experiences like with
instruments and music and it's like an
entire facet of our lives that
never really gets talked about on the
youtube channel so i thought it'd be
kind of cool to like
go around and like get each person's
story of like what's the what's the
instrument that they've devoted their
life to you know and like
how did that come to be and what kind of
fun stories do you have regarding it
i mean where do we want to start like
nico
what's your instrumental choice well
actually what do you what's your what's
your best instrument right now
the drums if you could re-learn
everything throw everything out the
window
and it'd be a master at one instrument
what would it be
probably the piano
all right sam yeah what are you saying
same thing what's your best instrument
um i mean piano and guitar is pretty
equal for me right now
so those are my main things that i use
for everything and if you had to drop
if i had to drop one geez i couldn't not
drop piano because it's the root of all
music for my opinion
because it's all the notes you know
they're all right there you don't have
to do all the
guitars are just like oh crap how do we
fit notes into this weird shape
you know yeah but whereas the piano is
just like no here here's just the
universal
layout you know um so i don't know
i kind of want to learn how to play like
some other like stringed instruments
like
wacky ass like weird viking instruments
but the problem with those is that you
you start playing them and you're like
oh sweet it's only like three strings
and it sounds like this
this weird rotting crow thing that's
happening and
and and you're like cool it's like crap
i can only make like
two or three chords with it it's like
super super limiting
yeah um that's that's the problem you
know
it's like guitar you can still there
it's a weird configuration there's
intervals and stuff but
all the notes are generally still there
um dude that's like freaking nick's
uh shrewdy box have you guys has he
showed me that thing yeah
yeah it's crazy it's literally like a
box that opens up
a little bit it pivots a little bit and
opens up like a briefcase
but it's connected like a bagpipe you
know or not an accordion
and then you have these valves to open
and close these holes to let air through
to make different cords and stuff and
you squeeze it and it like
it's like a yeah it's like a briefcase
accordion basically where you have it's
got holes
that release the air and it's funny
because it's like little switches or
like not even switches but there's just
like little
they're valves you just move the little
kappa side where you want the note
to be and then yeah it's it's really
it's really weird
dude freaking we had this
this moment on top of this mountain it
was the most amazing moment
it was one of the most amazing musical
moments that i've ever had in my life
and it was it was christian and it was
nick
and um this girl her name was
erratica and she sang in like sanskrit
or something like that
and nick had a shruti box and we were
just we were just jamming on the last of
us to
like soundtrack we were in yosemite okay
and we were just jamming on last with
two soundtrack it was a camping thing it
was late at night you see the stars on
top of this rock it's amazing
and how high were you guys no comment
and then um so then so then christian is
playing
last of us two on the bluetooth speaker
and this beautiful acoustic you know
little
little theme and nick is like
dude it's not gonna work my shrooty box
it only plays like three notes like sam
said no
these trudy box plays like a full like
scale and then some
it's like a scale yeah your limit you're
very limited it's in a key it's in a key
it is in a key but
like you have it's it's like a tiny
piano keyboard's worth of notes
or no no no it's not in a key no it's
it's just
all the notes and on all the half steps
and everything so then
he's like dude i can't hit this note
right now it's like the music's too
perfect
and christian's like dude just go for it
just hit the note just like see if it
works he's like there's no way he's
going
and he hits it he's like the first note
and it's perfect and we're like
oh my god and then radica she starts
singing
in uh some other language and she's an
incredible vocalist
and it this goes for like 10 minutes and
i'm just like oh my god and we're on top
of this rock
you see all these stars and we're like
i'm like i just start laughing super
hard because
it's too perfect and christian's like
dude shut up
[Laughter]
shut up just let it just like just
listen i can't i can't believe it okay
so actually that goes back to my main
thing
uh uh i wish i could sing better for
sure
that's like the main thing because it's
like it's god's instrument
you know what i mean like everyone has
it yeah everyone can play it if they
learn to practice
yeah uh clint what what about your uh
your opening question back to you uh
what was your what instrument are you
best at
and if you could start all over what
would you learn
i'm definitely best at the drums
i started on a marimba in eighth grade
so it was like it was
drum piano and it was like the perfect
mixture
dude marimba like like the jazz marimba
like the wooden one and the vibraphone
oh i'm thinking of vibraphones
i was at worst goose the other night
before everything
got closed yeah thank god i managed to
make it there um
there's a dude across the street playing
a freaking vibraphone
like the most jazzy chill vibraphone
i've ever heard and i thought it was
like a soundtrack or like a speaker
somewhere
uh and then i we're walking back and
there's a dude just going to be in
bamboo
but on this freaking huge vibraphone it
sounded insanely
like i don't know super talented on a
sidewalk yeah it's a sidewalk vibe
from what dude he like yeah tried super
hard to get that out on the sidewalk
it's crazy when people on the street can
perform music like that i i was in
venice beach one time and i was walking
by this uh
guy playing turntables and he was he was
live
yeah he was live scratching and live
switching
and i thought it was a pre-recorded
thing
um but then i i i didn't i just kind of
heard it and i just assumed that it was
like boardwalk music coming out of a
shop or something yeah
and then i and then as i got closer i'm
like wow that sounds like really present
and then i turn and there's this dude
just
going for it that's awesome yeah and
it was so flawless it was amazing you
know i think record scratches
you know is a part of music um really
need to come back
you know like the whistle right we're
you know like in all like japanese
it's like in every anime soundtrack you
know like ninja best
style it's like a break beat happens
every once in here some record scratches
and you're like damn getting
pumped yeah yeah yeah
and then you like if you have access to
a record table at some point like i
gotta try it
and you try to scratch it just sounds
like garbage that's so bad yeah and you
break the record player
well that all started from actually
scratching records
yeah yeah but it wasn't like they had
the pre-existing
third tables right no but yeah
was it like old school hip-hop and them
trying to like sample other
tracks and stuff well it's funny like
yeah yeah i mean you really take it for
granted that you just like play
different songs from different artists
back to back like back in the day you
literally had to change albums
that's crazy yeah and so like i was like
what if i had two albums playing
simultaneously
and i could just crossfade and
somebody's like what if uh i just
mixed it up a little bit and they did
like a little break beat yeah and i was
like wow just imagine having two
like legit record players happening and
you can hear both
in each ear and you're like okay here's
the next song and you're like speeding
up the record player slightly so that
like it
starts to line up with the next song you
know here we go oh god here we go and
then
you switch it height yeah you think like
you're at a party hit spotify and you're
like next and you're like
no yeah yeah
he does weddings he does like friends
weddings he does has been
messed with it a lot too yeah that's
hard stuff man that's like
really difficult it's fascinating wait
are you telling are you telling me that
if i get remarried
if i divorce wendy and marry her again
freddy will play my wedding yep
yes oh dude freddie is
an internet superstar and wedding dj
that's like exactly him though isn't
that like i've gotta do that
without saying too much i'm excited yeah
i'm excited
[Laughter]
so i'd kind of like to hear people's
stories maybe starting with uh with you
jake like
wait he's gonna wait he's ready to dj
your wedding
without saying too much i i i i just
admitted
you just admitted to it oh my god
what i'm going to do does he do record
scratching
physically i mean
maybe i don't know what's the dj name i
don't know
dj sound blaster okay if you had to
start all over again and
pick a new dj name clint what would it
be man
your current dj name i don't know it
doesn't matter because you're starting
over
um
i'm thinking like dj blowing dj buff dj
like
blow it out uh back i don't know
[Laughter]
i don't know all right
oops all right well that's it all right
all right dj blow it out the back
can someone drop the boom all right
can someone drop the blow it out the
back
niko jake same question
what's my dj you have to let go of your
current dj name and reinvent yourself as
a new dj what is that dj name
oh man dj little steps dj little steps
yeah little steps little steps
dj fleet dj fleet yeah
yeah dj sound blaster i guess after are
the best
sound driver there is dj real tech
dj real time that's a good one dj mario
[Laughter]
so you played do you play guitar right
like have you always played guitar
yeah um so uh i i
i have the classic story of like being
11 years old
and and and uh wanting to get a guitar
for christmas
and uh my buddy troy do you remember
troy rhoden
not really okay but he had this guitar
that had an amplifier built into it
now that to me that was the coolest
thing ever
because you could take it anywhere and
you could play electric guitar
anytime you wanted through an amplifier
so um
i went over to his house one day and we
and i started learning guitar
and he the first song he taught me was
uh some marilyn manson song i forget
what it's called it goes uh
na na na na na na
[Music]
oh no that's the cover of that 80s uh
song um
yeah uh sweet dreams yeah yeah
but so so manson did a did a version of
that and we thought it we didn't know
that it was a cover at the time we
thought it was a
a manson song so um so i learned that
song
and then i didn't tell my parents who
the artist was but i
got home and i was like look i can play
or we went to a music shop and i was
like look
i can play the guitar because my parents
said we'll get you a guitar if you can
play the guitar first
which is what they always did they were
like you you have to do this thing that
you don't know how to do
and we're not going to give you the
resources to do it until you
figure it out how to do it first which
actually made me pretty resourceful
honestly
no it's super smart yeah so so then they
got me guitar
and it was that it was the little like
uh you know pv
with a little pv amp those little pb's
man yeah mm-hmm
yep and i i i actually still in the
studio it's in
the uh i think it's in the boneyard in
the studio actually really
yeah um and so i got that and then
you know i just i kept playing kept
playing kept playing and then
uh i was in a band with a couple of guys
in high school we never did any shows or
anything but we would
play pretty frequently what was the name
of your band
uh i don't know if we had a name isn't
it called like fish pajamas or something
fish kebab well we had that was fish
keyboard that was another
band that we fish fish was our code name
for
for uh you know smoking weed marijuana
we
really you had that same code word too i
think because we we ended up calling it
that too we were like
going fishing it was me and david lovett
and like a couple other guys we took oh
vince rhodey was in it like we took a
photo at like
a lily lake of us all holding fishing
rods
together as like a memor like a you know
yeah memorial photo and like none of us
had ever fished
there together but we have a straight
foot of us all like
hanging out at the dock with fishing
poles yeah
yeah david i think david spread that
between
people and groups because you guys like
our my association to you is through
david
yeah originally and so he used to hang
out with us sometimes he hang out with
you sometimes and
and i think that's kind of how that
whole thing started there was this
there was this pond behind joe moore's
house that
actually ran and it was really cool
swimming spot in the summer
and we used to go back there and say we
were going fishing oh yeah
he'd come back and then just play music
in his living room
and so that's how he got the name fish
keyboard great
dude i'm gonna oh man i'm gonna have a i
got a great gift for you then
okay i can't tell you what it is because
then it'll ruin the surprise
and then and then i took that into
college and then i formed a a band with
a couple of my
uh trackmates and that that band was
called the lazy susans
um and we had some good tracks actually
we did three uh
like eps um that were
you know okay um our singer was the uh
not brett sorry if you're listening but
um you know our singer was
it was the hardest part uh of the of the
band
no uh brett okay not brett driver
another
buddy of mine yeah um
and then uh and then i had to learn
drums because our drummer went on
uh he went to study abroad for a year
and so
we did we were all the sudden without a
drummer so i was like uh i i guess i'll
play drums
um and we used to play in my dorm room
which was like
eight foot by ten foot and we had a
whole band set up in there and
and everybody in that dormitory hated us
because we would play and it was so
obnoxious but we would do it anyways
um because we you know we we loved
playing music
wow that's pretty crazy and and then
you moved to l.a yep and then uh my my
plan was to actually go to law school
and then become a musician's agent
um and then we started playing music
making videos yadda yadda
and then when i started playing with you
guys i switched it over to bass
because that's the that's the instrument
that we needed
yeah that's right bass was a lot of fun
um i actually want to get another one
because they man you can just get
they're so
it's like simplified guitar but what you
can work on when you play bass is you
can work on like your hand technique
and and and and that can get better and
better and better and it's and it's
almost a cross between drums and guitar
in a lot of ways totally um and that's
it's a really fun instrument
i hope you guys are enjoying your post
thanksgiving meal or maybe you're on
your way to thanksgiving or maybe it's
the day
after thanksgiving or the week after and
you're listening to this now maybe
maybe you don't even have thanksgiving
because you're international and you're
listening to this podcast
but happy black friday do they even have
that
in other countries i don't know anyway
the point is today's sponsor storyblocks
keeps this podcast going and they're a
huge asset for us over at corridor
digital and here's why they're the one
stop shop
for all of your stock asset needs
whether you're an individual creator
or a business or a creative agency it
doesn't matter
they've got everything from video and
b-roll
to after effects templates and audio
files
images all different sorts of things
that
make your life easier when you're
editing and creating they have an
unlimited all access plan
that allows you to download as much from
their site
that you want in an unlimited manner and
you can use it wherever you want that's
right wherever you want you can use it
in videos that you're monetizing
you can even use it in videos that
you're creating for other clients that
they're monetizing or that are
commercials for those clients and that's
the best thing about it that we like at
quarter digital it's relatively cheap
and inexpensive
for what it is they have a virtually
unlimited library online and they're
constantly updating it which means that
you're never going to go to the same
search and look for the same thing and
find
exactly the same assets that you already
used if you guys are interested go on
over to storyblocks.comcast to check it
out
that's storybox.com corridorcast and
hey you might find yourself on cyber
monday
using some stock b-roll because i bought
some socks
and you need to make a video of those
socks for your grandma
i don't know maybe that's one thing
you're interested in maybe
anyway that's it thank you for them for
sponsoring and now
back to the podcast let's go dude i
found
my rocksmith cables yesterday yes
it was in my base case wow yeah yeah
there's a phase where uh
because i played the drums um i didn't
start playing an instrument well i
played the clarinet briefly you know in
like school but uh i played the drums
started playing the drums in high school
um so my dad is a drummer
still is you still plays the drums um so
i kind of had some really really basic
intro drums then an uncle of mine passed
away and he had a drum kit that was just
sitting in my dad's
closet so i ended up taking that home
and practicing with it
um and we actually uh we tried to get
into the battle of the bands in high
school and senior year
and we literally formed our band the
night before battle of the auditions
and yeah went in and did the audition
and we didn't land
a slot for battle of the bands we were
the opener
for battle of the bands so yeah
playing we were the opener it was 2004.
okay i think i remember that yeah
because that's the year i went i think i
went sophomore year and senior year
yeah yeah i got to play in the high
school auditorium one time with my
brother
uh him and his buddies so i don't know
if you guys
remember but hulk hogan put out a record
at one point okay and he was trying to
do like the will smith thing
and um he put out a record and on that
record there was a song called beach
patrol
and it was like we are the beach patrol
we are the beach patrol and it was so
stupid um but we played it live and and
everyone just had a had a wicked good
time with it i don't know it was
that's something i was so i was so new
to playing guitar that i couldn't stand
and play
i had to sit i sat on an apple box and
like played while i was sitting down
because i was so scared that i would
mess up the song
if i stood up well um yeah
it was uh but it was super fun oh man
let me
i got one um
nico was a part of this one we played
uh do you remember the how they did the
coffee shop oh yeah
like the black box theater like coffee
shop style acoustic sessions
yeah yeah and yeah at our high school
so uh david and myself we were like
playing around with some music stuff and
we're like let's make a band where it's
all improvised music and so we just like
screw around and record like silly
vocals with the
synthesizer and we're like yeah this is
really funny what are we gonna call this
band we're gonna call the band
stonehenge
because like we just talk about like
outer space we just like griff on like
outer space and high concept stuff we
had no idea about but we like
talk it say like say things in like a
really like deep like
have you ever thought about how far away
the stars are you know because
this space is so big that you know you
get lost if you go up there
you know it's like crap like that um
yeah and so we messed around with it and
so this acoustic like chill like
like acoustic jam like performance that
was going to happen at the high schools
was going on and we were like hey
let's apply with stonehenge
and we we made it to the like the actual
show yeah
you guys got to the audition because in
the audition sam literally dropped his
pick
into his acoustic guitar and he's
standing there with it above his head
[Laughter]
yeah i i don't even remember i literally
don't even remember
that the fact that there was an audition
um but somehow our goodwill got us into
the actual show
and so basically we're like oh we
actually have to play live well like hey
nico you want to like play drums with us
for stonehenge now
you hit up joe like joe i need you on
base
for stonehenge and so we took these like
improvised songs about space and stuff
like this and like
they're like they were like looking back
on it but the lyrics were like horrible
um but we took these improvised songs
made like really rudimentary like rough
structures out of them so we could
actually like kind of play together
and uh we all came out in like hoods and
robes
and stuff
[Laughter]
we started we all start in like hoods
and robes like
like yeah like like like uh like
freaking like uh
uh like what is it like cult members
we all walk on stage and i take my
synthesizer and i like
i just blast the the lowest
note it's like brown and then david just
starts like rambling over it
and then we go into these that's like
like
like what were the songs called i can't
remember like what was called black hole
or like one was called like um
what's like the environment sucks or
something like that
something like that they're all they're
all just like the dumbest
like they're just edgy the dumb like
we were just trying to make them as
purposely like dumb and edgy as possible
and we and uh and so yeah what was the
reaction like what no what was it
well we went over a fair amount of
people that were laughing people started
laughing because it was so dumb
i mean it was obviously like goofy um
like what's that one song like when i'm
with you life is like a dream
i like my chips with sour cream
yeah yeah there's one song that was just
that
like it was like sandwiched with stuff
where we're talk we're just like saying
space space space
space like just chanting space with like
synthesizers and stuff like that
and then the last song the last song
like so we've finished this like weird
avant-garde set that's like mixed like
with just really edgy offensive stuff
and like just regular cute stuff
and stuff about aliens and then like it
ends with like
the uh sweet home alabama riff down
there i know i know i i i i scream
all right who's ready for a classic and
everyone's like woo
and i started like
yeah i start i start like i get like
three measures
into the songs and then laughing people
are ready
they start clapping along with me and
then i just like abruptly stop and we
all just leave the stage
that's all we know of this thing
[Laughter]
like oh yeah we know this one here we go
it's just like that then we'll put then
we just head out dude tastes so good
that's so freaking funny oh my god you
guys hadn't changed one bit then
we have we we have uh uh i actually have
the full tape of the events though are
you serious yeah
yeah dude that would be hilarious i
think i either saw
the tape of the event or i was there i
can't remember
i i remember i remember this you go
those those course of events that was
like charlie mccarron had that
somehow had the footage and he was like
hey hey check this out
and i was like oh my god so i just like
ripped it it's just sitting on a hard
drive now
yeah yeah incredible this isn't a hidden
feature in the second uh twisted studio
oh yeah yeah it's hidden features you
can save it before that drive
oh yeah who got into a pretty good punk
band was like david's buddies
and my buddies like connor and will
hayes
and uh and joe moore they actually
formed a punk band called the sleaze
that was like a
uh like a thrash sort of like punk band
and it was actually it was it was decent
like it was decent punk music
yeah there's that question when you
start getting into something like that
where it's like should i go hard on this
should i try to make this my thing you
make that jump
the thing that brought that that band
together was that will hayes was it was
a was a ridiculously good drummer
and then conor's voice was so absurd he
used to screech
when he would sing and they and like
they had songs
called like smoking [ __ ] cigs and
uh and songs like that and so it was
just like the classic like
teen angst but but taken to such an
extreme it was actually
pretty good yeah
i mean good times i remember jumping
ahead a little bit
there's a phase like you know i started
playing the drums in like high school
played them through college
and started playing them out here but
there was a phase i was like i should
start learning a melodic instrument
and this video game called rock band
came out which is basically just guitar
hero but with a real guitar
rock smith rock smith sorry not rock
band rock smith and uh yeah
it pulled me in and clinton ended up
getting sucked in too and we were just a
guitar
based duo where we just he played the
bass i play the guitar sometimes we
trade and we just play rocksmith like
every night for
like a couple months if not a year yeah
yeah we were into it dude we it got so
much fun like i got calloused on my
fingers and like
started to really get the hang of the
bass i still have my bass i like i said
found my cables
i would love to get down again yeah i'm
down i have my xbox 360 still
sweet you kind of learned how to play
guitar through that
yeah i legitimately learned how to play
guitar through rocksmith and then the
first thing for me
yeah yeah the funny thing is like i
still play the drums pretty frequently
but i play the drums basically to a rock
band drum chart like i have like 4 000
songs downloaded on my computer with
like a
program called phase shift and i have an
electronic drum kit so
arguably like out of all the video games
that i put most time into
i've actually put the most time into the
rhythm genre
like you know phase shift slash rock
band if you combine it all like i
probably put thousands of hours into
that at this point yeah
shift yeah face shift phase shift
phase shift okay because if it was
called face shift and it had morphing
faces while you played
depending on how hard you were rocking
but i'm totally down for another uh
rocksmith night yeah i mean or if
there's an equivalent you know
yeah like some some equivalent where the
things are coming oh man i don't think
there is i think it's just
it's dead dude guitar center freaking
filed for bankruptcy man
did they really yeah yeah physical
instruments are out these days
all the kids are just drawing like trap
beats yeah wow
are you serious dang yeah
well to be fair i kind of feel like
music is something that like the large
corporate
chain store like is gonna struggle to
provide like the local artists a better
experience than like a boutique mom and
pop like guitar shop
in my opinion yeah i mean i think it's
just the basic online retailer thing
sucking up everything but
i think there is also this genre shift
you know that's been
slowly happening but it's like kind of
clicking right now
there's a question of like why do i need
to learn an instrument when i can just
program my computer to play the song
instead if at the end of the day it's
just about the song
yeah if at the end of the music
performance is just hidden space on your
macbook you know dude there's nothing
more fun than live jamming
yeah and not knowing what you're gonna
play
and just vibing off of everybody and
listening to them
and trying to do your best to keep up or
to sit back
you know and like let someone do a thing
if you can get like
the right group of people together and
like we've all had some legit
jam sessions um some incredible jam
sessions
like that's like some of the best time
the best feelings that i've had like
ever yeah i know i feel
free it's but it's it's so cool when you
are like improvising like that you're
just jamming out
and then like all like the weird ideas
like are
just inching to each other and then
suddenly they kind of just click and
snap
and like you're like oh wow like this is
super cohesive suddenly like
we're all on the same like level finally
same rhythm we're in the same key we got
the same like
vibe it's like the genre kind of starts
clicking in a weird way
um yeah it's pretty nuts there's also
speaking you're speaking the language
with each other without
actually speaking like you know words oh
yeah 100
100 it's the best it really is
incredible
um but i was gonna use the example uh
there's a radiohead song it's called
bloom
and if you guys know um radiohead well
radiohead's like
one of my favorite bands of all time and
they have
some series called from the basement or
live from the basement
and um it's just them you know filmed
playing their albums from this basement
and it's like legit production
everything
they have a song called bloom and if you
get a chance
watch the song watch them play the the
live from the basement song
it starts out everyone's doing a
different thing
like drums guy goes like that
and then the bass is like and then the
guitar
and it like all just builds and builds
to like chaos like what am i listening
to and then it
syncs together during the chorus and
you're like what the heck it's the
coolest sound
it is so sick and like that's what it
feels like that's cool jamming is like
everyone's messing with these different
little things and then like playing off
each other and then it comes together
it's the best
that's cool clint how did you get into
the drums
i took
um i started drums in the eighth grade
and i was just in music class and i
started on the marimba
um and in
no sorry sorry seventh grade the seventh
grade eighth grade i joined drumline
so that just right into base four which
is the biggest bass
i got back problems did you watch did
you watch one of those movies drumline
before you joined the drumline
no no um my dad was a drummer
as well but i don't know what it was man
i think music theory in seventh grade
was it was very interesting i had a
really good teacher
um and that just got me amped up i just
want to play
and then eighth grade i joined drumline
um
and i want to tell you guys about
the worst concert i've ever been to i'm
just gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna bookmark
that
i'll talk about it in a second no no
we'll get to it i'll get to it i'll just
give you a little bit
so in drumline um it was the best made
some really good friends in drumline
and like i remember one time we were
going to do
a show a competition you know you
compete in drumline
and our you know instructor or teacher
he hyped it up he was like guys it's the
literally like
the friday before the state finals on
sunday no seriously it was the finals it
was
and he was like we're here waking up
early to practice
everyone get your game faces on each and
every one of you has worked so hard and
now is not the time to slack off
and because i think some people are like
showing up late and stuff and like as
soon as we get into eights which is just
like
one two three four five six seven eight
one two three alternating hands your
warmups
i freaking just tear my bass my bass
head just like
like oh crap god dang it dude so i like
miss half of that
and then i remember one time we skipped
drumline practice and my my uh
we skipped drumlin practice to get ice
cream to eat ice cream for some dumb
reason and
my friend talked me into it freaking
joseph talked me into it
the next day i roll up am i a band
teacher dude he was harsh he let me have
it he was like cussing me out really in
front of class
like yeah you're just a jackass like
only a jackasses do that and skip class
he was like all serious about it um
but yeah dude if we went on i actually
we went to
we played carnegie hall
i was in i was in uh i was in eighth
grade band
and we were the third junior high to
play carnegie hall
and we went to new york for two weeks
and my mom was there
and it was like it was so nerve-wracking
dude
it was just like it was awesome a blur i
don't really remember it um
you wouldn't that's what i'm sorry that
reminds me of just a stupid
stupid i thought um like one of my
earliest memories
um and the reason it's one of my
earliest memories and why i've
remembered it so long is because
of how embarrassing it is um yes
and it was i think one of the first i
think it was the first
concert that i can remember going to
it was the san francisco symphony
orchestra
and i think i was like maybe like four
or five years old
oh man you remember this yes because it
was like a kindergarten
or like first grade thing i can't
remember and it was like this is a big
deal it's like guys we're bringing
this whole kindergarten class to see an
orchestra for the first time is a field
trip
and like we're gonna experience
classical music you know it's like
bringing these kids out to this thing
there's like a whole small section of
just like kindergartners
high up high very we it's nosebleeds you
know like we're
so we're very very far away from the
stage we're like up
and like far up to the left like three
stories yeah okay
really far away and the teacher's like
look we're going there so here's the
rules you're gonna be quiet you know
when the music is playing
not gonna be eating food don't bring
toys don't do anything like this
because this is there's like also many
people who are paying like hundreds and
dollars for their tickets to go to this
thing so
you know be you know be at your best and
so we go up there to the like the
nosebleeds super far away
and the music starts playing and i was
like
uh if do you remember those yo-yo balls
do you remember yo-yo balls i remember
yo-yos they're like yo-yos but
instead of like a yo-yo it was just like
a
ball with like
like a like a like an elastic or like
spring wound
line so you could just flick it like
automatically come back
look the concert's playing and i'm just
like oh man
like i got this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it pops off my finger and like
rolls down like this slick
like barrier that's like running to me
it
shoots off and it like flies like three
stars
like crashes right in the middle of the
violence sex
and like like i remember it was
so vivid like i remember saying it like
like terminal velocity from like three
stories onto the stage
and like i just remember seeing it like
hit and start rolling and like
some of the violence stopped like one
stops playing and like tries to like
stop it like rolling across the stage
with their bow
oh wait and so like did the audience
know like there's kindergarteners
joining us
ah oh god
dude that must have been so loud like
hard wood this is like damn it's just
like
a hammer oh do you know this didn't
really beat a freaking like first chair
yeah i just didn't i'm glad it didn't
hit anyone but oh my god
that would have went into someone's tuba
it was so loud
yeah it just hits the drum like i was
just frozen with fear of that
well yeah it's all in slow motion the
whole time you get in trouble
the memory cut short there uh after
before the beatings but i'm still here
i'm still here apparently things went
pretty well for me after that
wow dude that is an incredible story
yeah that one's a that's a that one's a
good one
all right i think gideon's gonna do
something like that in the next like
six years oh definitely oh yeah brother
definitely what's the worst concert
you've ever been to all right the worst
okay here's the thing
it was the worst concert experience of
my life but it was the most memorable
concert experience in my life
nico christian you've heard me tell us
right twice and then nico have you heard
me say this
don't think so i'm so excited okay um so
there's a ambient band called stars of
the lid
oh if you don't know who stars of the
lid is just
just google it youtube at spotify
whatever it's literally the most chill
music it's just like
[Music]
that's it it's like literally music to
relax like
soft strings very sparse piano notes
super harmonic it's like literally
it's music to like do yoga to or sit on
a mountain and like
relax and meditate exactly it's very
peaceful ambient music
and um my buddy john carman he was like
yo
they're in town and i'm just like no way
dude because i love these guys so much
so i me my buddy adam and john carmen we
all go to see
them at the will turn i think in uh
k-town
and we are so hyped man and they get
going two guys it's two guys
they come out on a stage and one guy
seems a little off
one of the dudes seems a little off um
and whatever they get into it
and you know they get into the most
quiet peaceful oh it's a quartet with by
the way
playing with a quartet so it's two guys
in the in a string quartet
and they get into it and like five to
ten minutes in
i noticed something very subtle that is
really ruining the vibe and if you
listen really closely you can hear like
[Music]
it was this mexican pirate radio that
had like snuck into the airwaves
and it was like
and it was like ruining it like normally
that wouldn't ruin a show because it's a
rock concert it's loud like not a
problem
but dude it's an ambient concert and
like it's so quiet the whole time
and they matter no matter how like
laughing
oh my god you're gonna hear like that
like there's like ranchero
horn tears it's blasting like
but it's on one percent volume right
yeah it's
so then i realized one of the main guys
was drunk
oh he was drunk and he was like in the
middle of the show
he notices it so he's like he starts
turning himself up he's like turning up
his guitar
so it's like getting really loud like
like
like really loud and so loud like he
start
he's looking to the guy in the back the
mixer in the back and it's a small room
and he
is just playing his peaceful hammering
song and then turn me up
and you're just like in the middle of
this like peaceful show and you're like
oh my god
[Laughter]
so he gets the point he turns up so that
he blows his speaker
what yeah he blew his that would have
been so loud
so he blows that speaker and at one
point
his freaking his his bass guitar oh that
was like first ten minutes his bass
guitar dropped like the
the latch came loose and went
it was like middle of the middle the
most peaceful music you've ever heard
this quiet like talents
[Laughter]
it's not going over dude
he like gets to the point where he's
just trying to drown out this mexican
pirate radio because it persists
it keeps going so there's a part of the
song where it's just like
a really intense you know when songs get
all distorted and they like get all
washy and it like gets louder and louder
and then like the other song just cuts
off like a trend razor song or something
it was one of those situations so he was
building building
building and there was a video screen
and it was just playing like fire
animations
and you're the string quartet sitting in
the middle
and they were just going like that
and they kept getting higher higher and
faster and faster and faster and faster
and they played it for 20 minutes he
kept getting he kept making them play he
made them play for 20 minutes straight
he was just like keep going he was and
he was on his guitar so he was like
and the string was like and they were
just like
dude they looked like they were going to
die they were sweating so hard and like
when you were doing that sam with your
high string like
yeah they were just
for 20 minutes straight so he nearly
killed the string quartet
and then he's so drunk he starts hitting
all these wrong keys and stuff
um and then it gets to the point where
the end of the show comes
and um you know they finish the show
aft with a blown speaker and a jacket
guitar and like he's all drunk and stuff
and everyone's clapping yeah he starts
the lid
and he finishes their song he's like
goodnight and he just leaves there's no
encore there's
nothing he was so pissed dude wow i'm so
pissed
so then i looked at my friend adam i'm
like did you catch any of that he's
like no i thought i thought it was a
good show like i didn't catch any of
that stuff
wow wow so i guess he was in the zone
and me and
me and john carman i guess we're like in
the zone i don't know
can you imagine if you were can you
imagine if you were like
listening to that if they had if they
had captured that for like a studio
recording
and you're you're you're in like a
massage parlor
and you're getting this just
it gets on that track and the person
doesn't know that it's
this jank recording oh man it kind of
reminds me of a show that uh
sam and i went to and recall it in
college it was uh death clock was
touring basically it's brandon small
you know the guy that wrote the uh the
show and all the music touring with like
steve vi's like backup guitarist and a
couple other like
good musicians studio musicians and so
they were playing in madison wisconsin
and the opening act was this band i
think you will notice by the trail of
the dead was their name or something
like that okay
it's like this kind of metal thrashy emo
band and like they were not very good no
one was there to see these guys but like
they came out on stage like
we're the headliners and no one knows
who these guys are it's like they
immediately start like at like 11 with
the energy
and it throws people off a little bit
especially because the music's like
really grating
and like they start getting to like you
know like the really like climactic like
i'm smashing my guitars
i'm throwing into there i'm screaming in
the microphone it's raw emotion like
they just went there immediately yeah
and like they hadn't earned it they
weren't ready for it the crowd wasn't
ready for it and people like start
getting pissed off and like it gets to
the point like everything's mixed so
poorly and they're so loud
like literally the lead singer starts
taking his guitar and just scraping it
on the amp
like strings down on the edge of his
hand and he's like
shut up like somebody throws a drink at
the guy like get off the stage
and like the guy's like you know his
back is the only he's just like chugging
on his guitar he just stops
and it's quiet and just walks off and
that was the end of their act wow oh my
god
yeah i would have felt bad for them if
they hadn't like assaulted our ears
by like scraping the guitars like on the
amps it's just kind of like an fu to the
audience a little bit it's horrible
okay what what what are the best
concerts you guys have ever been to
i feel like my best concerts that i've
experienced are ones that i don't
actually actively like seek out
like there's a there's like a mini
concert that i went to
um so we mentioned him earlier but
sergio flores like the sexy sax man
as you know on youtube from like 20
2012. um
so he invited us to a little me and ivy
invited us to a little show he was doing
where like somebody like a friend of his
was like trying to do he's like put
together these like little events where
the idea is to have people come over
you serve them like a dinner and then
you have like a show and it's all just
like in like a downtown loft kind of
situation
and so we're having this dinner and the
loft is basically just a small concrete
box
but the people they brought in are all
basically street performers so
they're solo acts and when you put one
of those kind of people in a small
concrete box you just get beautiful
reverb
and like it sounds great you know versus
like having like five or six instruments
this immediately becomes a mess
and like the people that were performing
there like in that experience is just
like
world class like holy moly these guys
are
good and they're like three feet in
front of me playing to an audience of
like eight people
and it was like one of those things was
like this is not the fact that they got
like five artists to get together
and like put put like a good show
together for like eight people
was crazy and like i'll never get
another experience like that so that one
sticks out to me
hmm yeah
small venues are great no venues are
great like when you get the right
uh and and big venues can be amazing too
it just depends on the type of music
small venue one time i went and saw uh
jamestown's earl who's like a he's like
a folk
kind of singer um and uh
that was that was really cool um there's
this place off of in west la
off of like barrington that's the small
little hole in the wall place that he
played and it was really intimate and
fun
it was cool i think like smaller the
better
like you i think you can go you probably
can go too small no i don't know if you
can go too small
like bathroom stall kind of a bathroom
stall could you remember when
we were out on our bikes and uh we came
across the vibrometers playing at
dylan's tavern well we didn't know who
the heck they were yeah at the time but
we were like
yeah we were on our bikes right mm-hmm
and yeah we just randomly came across
this band
in a bar and we're like wow they sound
so good did we go inside yeah we went
inside listen to him and they were
really good like everybody was tight
they were grooving like
they're into it like and just the music
was popping
yeah it was a that was amazing
definitely love
love it when you come into those like
little random situations like that i
remember i was in um
last year for my birthday i was in
ireland and
we went into a pub it was like late
night i went to just get
i don't know what i went to do i was
just hanging out
and just two dudes one guy on a on a
guitar and one got a flute
and they were going so hard it was
amazing yeah
i don't know who they were but yeah
irish irish pub music can be
can be awesome um we had a lot of that
at notre dame where i went to school and
uh
and there's some really good really good
mems from
irish pubs yeah yeah well
it's my uh i gotta put my kids to bed
here guys i gotta
think about heading out here all right i
think we should think about
wrapping up this podcast though
my favorite one was definitely my first
like metal concert i went to which was
like in flames
and soil work and it was just like i was
like here's the first time i'm gonna go
see a concert like a music genre i
really
like i'm into so to speak um and it was
like super intense
because like the first song was just
like like a sort of work song where it's
like
just intense double battle double pedals
like right away
and just like holy [ __ ] this is so loud
and then like
literally everyone's just like
compresses to the front of the stage i'm
just like
but i can't breathe and it's just like
the loudest music and i can't breathe
um and that was like really great start
to the concert
uh and yeah i was like hell yeah this is
the best i didn't think
i picked the right genre amazing show to
go to yeah
before with all like the original
lineups all the original guitarists and
stuff it was
awesome okay i got i got two things to
say before we close
uh one should we green light a corridor
album
uh let us know on that
um and then two uh we're dropping a
bunch of merch
tomorrow right so uh if you guys
are interested in getting something for
friends or family
uh cord or digital.store and if you
remember
oh it just keeps getting better you
should check this stuff out
every time we release stuff it gets
better yeah these are really nice shirts
i mean i'm wearing one right now
you guys wearing one it's cool go hiking
with your robot dog
everyone loves that one i think that
one's gonna do well
i think so too also this hat my my
special hat is now available for
everybody nico's special hat you just
type in nico's special hat you'll find
it nico's special
special barge hat that sat on a barge
for nine months
uh cool so and if you're a member of our
site obviously you get 15 off all merch
all the time so
uh cool that was that was fun um
let's do another one so yeah i didn't
even get to talking about my handpan so
lots of we'll have to do a follow-up
next time we'll actually
be playing more music i think yeah same
as all these instruments at home
yeah i'll bring i can bring some stuff
in we're gonna go
play it in practice the night before for
the for the battle of the band's
corridor cast
yes corridors about all the bands
happy i'll see you guys later
see y'all see jake bye see all you
listeners
thanks for tuning in
[Music]
haha